десь на бахмутській ділянці фронту
замаскувавшись у лісопосадці причаївся
український артилерійський
розрахунок через півтора року війни їхня
тактика
змінилася раніше ми працювали мобільно
то есть виїхали відстрілялися і сходу
втікли з того Ну вогнева пересиділи
з'явилася ціль опять виїхали
отстрілялись уїхали А зараз все закрито
позиція отак у нас зараз
відбувається чому так можна зрозуміти зі
звуків у повітрі над лінією фронту
постійно кружляють безпілотники
артилерійське знаряддя ласі цілі для
обох сторін тож Часто можна почути
вибухи від
прильотів раніше артилерісти відкрито
пересувалися дорогами нині намагаються
ховати техніку частковий захист дає
каркас із дротяної сітки дрони Камікадзе
вибухають врізаючись у неї а не в
бронетехніку
ця гаубиця на озброєнні вже кілька
десятиліть у Радянській армії артилерію
називали на честь квітів приміром ця
називається
гвоздика сучасні західні установки
звісно ефективніші але поступаються
гаубицями радянської доби у швидкості
обслуговування та
ремонту
гумором таким скажу що ми можем піти
майже любу деталь купити допустим в
автомагазині якомусь А если допустим
виходить зі строю натовська техніка Нам
потрібно буде там визивати спеціальних
людей там спеціальними там
інструментами Екіпаж отримує координати
цілі та швидко готується
я постріл відпрацювавши Вони одразу
відходять подалі від гаубиці кожен
постріл з цієї позиції збільшє
ймовірність бути виявленим
є таке
загальне така загальна думка що вони там
ідіоти от як це далеко не так Вони теж
вміють воювати Вони знають що вони
роблять вони розвиваються вчаться Ну і
ми не
відстаємо САУ знову ховають і під
захисним каркасом тепер вона схована від
Дронів і гвоздика чекає свого наступного
завдання
те що Росія значно покращила свої
військові спроможності підтверджують і
західні військові експерти і за
застерігають це справді несе серйозні
загрози Росія адаптувалася Вона має
доволі просунуті можливості електронної
боротьби та глушіння сигналу вона також
збільшила виробництво Дронів Вона має
велику кількість артилерійських знарядь
які вона отримала і ще отримає додаткову
артилерію наприклад з Північної Кореї Ми
звичайно знаємо і про безпілотники та
ракети з Ірану
і Росія загалом має більший потенціал
для виробництва зброї вона перевела свою
економіку на воєнний лад вона нарощувала
своє військове виробництво таким чином
що змогла певною мірою обійти санкції
крім того у неї набагато більше
чоловіків тож Україні потрібно зараз
певною мірою врівноважити це більш
просунутими
технологіями це розуміють і союзники
України на початку тижня з наголошеним
візитом прибув до Києва глава пентагону
Лойд Остін за його словами новий пакет
військової допомоги від США на 100 млн
доларів охоплює зокрема зимове
спорядження і ЗСУ загалом мають
необхідні засоби щоб домогтися успіху в
боях узимку - запевнив
Остін Я думаю українські військові
готові до бойових дій взимку і звісно
торік вони виконали чудову роботу цього
року ми очікуємо що вони будуть
базуватися на тому що сказав прези
Зеленський щоб вони були ще навіть більш
агресивними одразу за остіном до Києва
прибув і міністр оборони Німеччини Борис
пісторіус і теж оголосив про новий пакет
військової
допомоги у цей пакет входять ще чотири
системи і слм артилерійські боєприпаси
калібру 155 мм і протитанкові міни
загалом це пакет на 1 мільрд 300
мільонів євро і Я впевнений що цей уже
п'ятий пакет від минулої зими допоможе
вам у боротьбі з російською
агресією у перші місяці війни військові
оглядачі дивувалися як повільно і
незграбно російські війська змінювали
свою тактику після провалу плану Київ за
три дні Нині ж сталися серйозні ЗМІ
іроя спромоглася адаптуватися до нових
реалій
вистріл якщо ти не адаптуєшся ти помреш
і росіяни адаптувалися зокрема Вони
намагаються завести війну в глухий кут
Тож вони звели великі Мінні поля та дуже
потужну оборону на передові тому що вони
розуміють що якщо їм вдасться нав'язати
таку війну як зараз з невизначеними
рухами з обох сторін то зрештою щось
станеться наприклад унаслідок
президентських виборів у
США це означатиме що підтримка заходу
може це неонозначно але може зменшитися
І це дає Росії можливість заморозити
лінію фронту на більш тривалий період на
більш довгострокове розмежування
території Ось що зробила Росія вони
перейшли до повністю оборонної війни в
Надії що з часом щось станеться що
допоможе
їм тим часом Українські війська зокрема
тут під бахмутом готуються не лише до
адаптованої тактики росіян а й до
холодів замість цієї багнюки Незабаром
буде сніг це вже не перша зима на фронті
для цього командира підрозділу
рсзв минулої зими ми працювали трошки
по-іншому ми майже постійно знаходились
на вогневих позиціях більше працювали в
нас більше було
боєприпасів то ми ну десь доба через
добу чергували тому що довше Ми в нас не
було таких умов Там ми не в нас не
вириті були бліндажі ну зараз в нас
звичайно більше
підготованіми нині розповідають у цьому
підрозділі докучають не лише російські
війська а й миші це не просто неприємно
а й небезпечно бо вони перегризають
кабелі в техніці та роблять іншу шкоду
вони без бронежелітів провли прошлу
зимку мищей я якось не замічав щоб було
ну це ця осінь ця уже начало зими можна
сказать
то дуже
багато не знаєш як з ними боротись От
наприклад Сьогодні я ліг спати положив
цю
флісочку під голову утром прокидаюся А в
мене вже тут циферки тут буковки уже
вона позіда
військові кажуть що до зими вже
більш-менш підготувалися є дизельні
обігрівачі теплий одяг та віра в
перемогу